so when I start my concert I like to
face my back towards the audience to
build anticipation so that way they
think oh no who's coming onstage it's me
oh my god I'm so excited
thanks I would be too so whatever
negative energy you have within you you
gotta let it out you can't let anything
stand in your way
cuz when you sing it's all about
aggression and anger and passion and
love and hate let's say Britney or pink
or Lady Kaka comes at me I'm not gonna
say come a me bro I'm gonna say come at
me brah
Oh
ah right
[ __ ] [ __ ] Fox it's really hard for
me to describe these techniques to
regular people oh that was good oh great
I can see where it will go oh that was
okay I'm not threatened by other singers
I'm not oh maybe it's only something I
could do like this oh okay I get it
Oh what's up come here for a sec oh
honey are you okay maybe you should let
your voice red ribbon who's next
I said who's
I'm Christina Aguilera and this is my
singing class 10:00 a.m.
practice dance moves that are all elbows
and shoulders and practice puppeyface